[Music]
I mean as you were coming up with the
story the two of you and by the way I
should write you you guys are also a
married couple writing about a very
complicated interesting marriage coming
with the story of it as you were
brainstorming these characters and how
you wanted to tell this were you ever
worried that this might be too much for
people that people might be like I can't
empathize with anybody on this screen
like where did you find The Bravery to
write it the way feel like it had to be
done well I mean I think that that's
what's exciting about it to to me and to
us that um these characters are um very
complicated and uh reprehensible and a
varying levels getting to have a bit of
remove a bit of space to watch them um
is
is is very interesting to me as a writer
and and to us as a and yeah yeah just
thinking of it from the perspective of
an actress coming in to study them
seemed like the best way to with a
little bit of her move kind of see
something that's so tragic but then also
be able to have humor and some satirical
elements in there too um and kind of
indict an indictment of you know the
audience watching these things and
people that like us that watch these
things and consume these things right
that already probably I think all of us
walked into the theater with opinions on
like the real life story of bringing
this listen to the theater as well I
mean what did Tom what did what did Todd
ha say really early on that made you
feel like oh he absolutely gets it oh
well I
mean when they said that Todd was
interested in wanting to to do this it
was um like a lightning bolt of
euphoria um and and it it makes so much
thematic sense I mean it's if we had put
Todd on a corkboard we would have seemed
delusional
at the time but it does it you know the
the way he plays with themes of identity
and and performance and fame and all of
these things it it it's been such a gift
I mean I'm just really struck by the
challenge that you two set out for
yourself like this is a film that's
exploring characters who absolutely
refuse to explore themselves and be
introspective under any circumstance
whatsoever I mean that is is so hard I
can imagine to figure out how to put
that on screen when they're not willing
to go
there yeah I mean it's it's kind of I
think what makes especially Gracie a fun
character to write
because um there's so much denial
there's so much denial of reality and um
the gap between what she's saying and
and what we feel is so vast that it it's
can be really physically
uncomfortable yeah I mean it looks
physically comfortable to beat Charles
Melton in this film yeah yeah and also I
was thinking I mean this goes even for
the character of Elizabeth that Natalie
Portman plays you know she comes into
this film speaking the language of like
feelings and empathy and like talking a
good game of being an emotional person
but you put in the script little moments
of
seeing that she's got her own
complicated love life with her fiance
who she doesn't always feel like talking
to and something happened with her
director and there are stuff that she's
not talking about
either as she's prying them but you show
us that she's that what we're seeing is
not the real her necessarily either
absolutely I I think the the ways in
which we uh get information about
Elizabeth um and how slowly
our our trust in her as a narrator as an
entry point uh starts to dissolve uh
really is is I think part of the fun of
of the movie
I mean one interesting kind of fun fact
about your background is your mother was
a casting director you grew up I think I
can imagine you was a small child with a
crayon book keeping yourself busy being
surrounded by actors trying to get aart
in those waiting rooms and so and then
you grew up to like do a lot of casting
work yourself you cast um the first
Hunger Games I was the location casting
assistant in North Carolina you
basically like cast Jennifer and made
her ex I found Jennifer in a
diner but I just love it because that
makes me feel like you in particular
have such
a special and kind of particular insight
into the world of what will people do to
get apart that's
true that is very oddly Darkly true I
think that there something about um yeah
sometimes I go why was I there you know
what I mean why was I after school like
sitting in produ ction offices like I
would sometimes I would be under my
mom's desk and like to and I would hear
people come in and say the same line
over and over and over and over and and
I do have weird memories of like weird
women figuring I mean not just women but
I have specifics of of of like kind of
like hot actresses being like Oh hey
what are you doing you know like as I'm
a child do my homework you know like
they think going to go in and go that
girl you should give her this one liner
in Vegas Vacation like you
should it's it's very demented and so I
think that that that kind of energy is
just so infused in in um yeah my
upbringing oh yeah and you put it also I
think in such good use here on the
screen when you show us Elizabeth
looking at the reals of young boys
auditioning to play the Joe part and I
think I'm so glad you wrote that scene
in because for me watching this as an
audience member and I'm sure people in
here felt the same way that's when you
kind of take a breath and you're like oh
right he was that young yeah yeah yeah
it's a a sobering moment um absolutely
and we tried to build in those gradually
just these con these reminders that kind
of Flip Flip your stomach but also
getting I we got an email of those kids
those aren't their real names saying Hi
here's my real name here is my slay and
then they start the scene and then they
those are their lines so it's like the
meta very
surreal qualities of this really never
sto being very strange and funny well
yeah it does feel like one of your dark
jokes at the end is like when we see the
film finally being made those guys were
not cast in this film it feels like she
kind of got the honier 13-year-old she
wanted I hate that I'm saying that out
loud yeah this sort of yeah the reveal
of the movie they're making
I mean we get hints that maybe it's not
um bad lands exactly what they're doing
but um when you finally see it you're
like oh my goodness like I love the the
way Todd chose to shot to shoot it all
and and the all the creative choices
that are so different than the ones he
makes I mean it made me wonder when you
guys were coming up with this character
of Elizabeth was there a moment where
you had to decide is she a good actress
like well we always knew deep
down maybe I you know it's more about
her intentions you know and um how what
she thinks of herself like going to this
town and like having this experience
like as an actress which is like so kind
of lofty um and then yeah just to see
the the final product is like it's not
what she really wanted maybe or not what
she get her off her network FAL animal
Hospital TV show probably noris arc
noris Arc I want to imagine you guys
eating toast at your house and you come
up with norz Arc over coffee in the
morning these are the kind of things
that we love talk about but it is true
and I think that actually kind of adds
to the empathy of the film that like
there are people who are like the most
talented person in like their high
school performing it's great people who
take their craft really seriously who do
wind up giving arars and enema for the
rest of their life on television as a
sitcom and like that that gap between
like a a creative person's Ambitions and
then what they wind up doing is kind of
painful absolutely I mean that the look
in Natalie's eye at the very that last
shot is um is heartbreaking because it's
so insecure I to me that you know
there's so much doubt um and and you can
do all of
this you could really sell your your
soul to a certain extent and um and and
what's it really all for you know yeah
and yeah I mean one of the things in
here that I really love that you took
care to do with this script is you give
us scenes of of Gracie and Joe alone
when they're not being observed by her
you give us scenes of what they're like
when nobody's watching because this is
so much a movie about people watching
each other
I mean tell me about figuring out how
you wanted those scenes to go or what
you wanted us to take away from the
couple when they're just them being
them yeah well I think that
um there is such a a TW sidedness to
Gracie that's really the whole thing
orbits around of what does she know what
does she think why did she do this you
know that the the discomfort of how hard
that is to to figure out as an audience
member as the writer as as Elizabeth and
and especially as Joe and the only
person that's really um dedicated to not
asking those questions it seems is is
Gracie herself um but I think
that you know Joe being the heart of the
story always felt important right from
the beginning um that this this pivotal
moment you know it's almost his come of
age I think um right on the precipice of
graduation with this doppelganger that's
the same age as him now you know I think
it's not that it was smooth sailing up
until that point I think the these are
the last two drops before the dam breaks
you know and
um yeah getting to see these
particularly Joe by himself you know
there's he's very protected in the movie
um in these small quiet scenes Watching
This Old House um until he's not until
he kind of steps forward and um reminds
us I think yeah a lot of the SC that I
wound up really thinking about
afterwards and there's sort of two that
I'd love to talk about Joe with his dad
I'd love to start there with that scene
yeah um that was
um there used to be a lot more said in
that scene and it and we you know pulled
it back as much as possible um because I
think there is no what can be said you
know um I think that look I love I love
that that look through through the
cigarette um that that they share and
um I think that says it all really you
know but that was a CH that was an
interesting part of the process in in
getting beautiful notes from Todd one of
my favorite notes right from the
beginning was he said add more fog which
is like so
gorgeous and I think that was a good
example of that scene of because this is
so much about repression and um the ways
in which he h he is unprocessed he has
not been able to not had time to so um
that really um that's a good example of
some fog I think that one and I also
like the moment he has those two moments
where you see him as just a father alone
the one on the roof is beautiful and
then there's that just tiny one on the
morning graduation where they're like
futzing around and maybe she's getting
at a maybe she's at a beauty paror and
you see him as as a happy Dad as well
and I thought that was beautifully
written thank you thank you
yeah um I think that uh it was always
important to us that
Joe he's a caretaker you know some
partially he's been forced to be for for
Gracie but he's um he is a good father
and and he took on this
responsibility before he was able to
really choose to be able to and and the
kids are so wonderful and I think that's
what complicates the whole thing for him
um but yeah we I think from the very
start it was you know it is a balancing
of tones um but there we wanted there to
be room for these moments of that are
are hopeful or or beautiful
yeah I mean I think the moment that I
feel like I absolutely have to ask her
everybody like why didn't we talk about
that is the letter the the letter that
Natalie reads and that that just amazing
sequence tell me about drafting that
scene um it's it's pretty long in the
script it's
few pages of of monologue um and I you
know it felt like there just are so few
opportunities where people are saying
something honest in the whole thing and
and that's not honest but there's so
much information that we get and the way
that um to I mean Todd's spoken about
that that was the thing that made him
want to do the movie was the idea of
filming Natalie doing this monologue two
camera you know inspired by bergman's
winter light um which was also a letter
um and I think that is so it's it is
it's so emotional especially on the big
screen I think because you know you you
feel what Joe the amount of pressure you
know you see Gracie more clearly you see
things she's she's been dishonest to us
about but also the amount of pressure um
I think is is really effective just
right to us
yeah it's true I remember I remember
feeling like oh I'm really kind of
convinced and I want to believe like we
want to believe that people are telling
us the
truth yeah yeah yeah I mean I know that
we all kind of wish that our actors
could be here on this circuit talking
about the work that they've done I mean
absolutely love to be able to like have
you know Jillian and Natalie and Charles
up here but since we can't I would love
to hear from you guys who know these
characters so well tell me about about
you know you wrote these characters you
put them on paper you had your ideas of
them but I'd love to hear about each of
these actors what's a little moment a
little bit in this movie a little scene
something that you just thought oh wow
they got
this I mean there's so many it's really
hard with the actors of this quality to
single out any one moment but I remember
first when we first watched it and just
seeing how Charles carried himself that
it it both held this young boy and this
old man all at once and there's that one
shot when he's walking up to his
father's house and you kind of see it in
the wide and just the way he's kind of
shambling along I mean it just like it
says so much without saying anything you
know um just in this quiet moment and
you really you could see it throughout
the entire movie with his performance
just this kind of beautiful physicality
that he brought to it um you it's a
shame that I mean hopefully this will
soon and he could join us I know I I
also love um every time I've seen it
I've noticed different moments tiny
moments where where Natalie chooses for
Elizabeth's mask to to slip mask to slip
a little bit um and say something honest
or or has a kind of human expression and
um those are really beautiful anchors I
think also the lisp is pretty
that was something it was a shock to us
we saw the film just a genius Julian
brilliant and it gives something for
Natalie to latch on to and she's
creating that character or for Elizabeth
to latch on to yeah cuz they really had
no they had no rehearsal and they were
just in Savannah it's they had 23 days
to shoot this movie and um and when you
think of the levels of I mean they
scheduled it some where there was you
know I think the monologue was one of
the last things um but to she was having
to calculate a performance in real time
just as Elizabeth is which is so
interesting well we should wrap up but I
do want to ask before we go I want to go
back and talk about that last scene just
one last time because when I was
watching that I almost felt
like having gone through all of this
heartache and struggle to make this
movie it almost felt like to me the last
scene was saying you know one way people
might Define a movie is the struggle to
put the truth on screen and how almost
perhaps almost impossible of a quest
that really is and I wanted to ask you
if if you felt that or if that was
something that drives you as you
continue creating thinking brainstorming
stories on your breakfast table yeah I
think it it's definitely a part of the
the question you know I think there is
in this case it's there's a fool
hardiness of Elizabeth to try to capture
the truth of this very
complicated situation and um and I I
think we question why it is that we feel
compelled to to rehash um famous
horrible stories like this over and over
um but then you
know sometimes you capture the truth so
it there is a there's a a question more
than a a statement I think as far as our
our in our interest
yeah yeah certainly we're always like we
just got to be
truthful of course we're saying those
same things that she says and I don't
know it's part of the process I
guess well Alex Samy thank you so much
for being here to talk to us about this
film guys thank you so much for coming
spread the word about May December make
sure everybody watches this
[Music]
film